you have mentioned in the past a
personal success system what is what is
a personal success system I think
everyone on the planet has a personal
success system they just might not know
exactly what it is and some friends who
popped in mind are the friend called
Shona who has a business called perfect
English grammar and her personal success
system is going to events because what
she finds is that every single time she
goes to event she'll meet someone she'll
get an idea she'll she'll something will
happen and in the six months after her
business doubles and that's happened
like three times now so because she
knows what it is what her personal
success system is she can apply this
going forward and she can just go to
bigger and better events and she can she
can kind of take the cruxs of this
system and just keep applying it and
everyone's second favorite billionaire
Jeff Bezos has a very similar thing
where he
he will think of an idea he will write a
onepage press release about it he will
see how that goes down with a very small
group of people and then he'll just
build it and then he knows that a few of
them are going to take off some of them
aren't Amazon's got like 157 businesses
that it started that didn't go anywhere
like you remember the dash buttons and
the um and the fire phone and like
random stuff and it's like yeah we'll
give it a go might work might not that's
like his success system is coming up
with the idea writing the press release
releasing it and seeing what happens and
I realized that I had one too where if I
look back at anything that I'm like
proud of or anything I've achieved I
pretty much followed the exact same
system to achieve it and so this is
going to be different for everyone but
mine is set the intention speak to
someone who's done it ask them how they
did it find out a method and then split
that method into something that I do
every single day for about half an hour
and just keep going until it happens
that's just that's just my success
system and so when I worked this out I
was like I need to test this with other
things so the next thing I had in mind
was to write a book and get a publisher
so I followed the exact same process and
it just worked and there's almost
something in like when you figure out
what your unique resources are what your
unfair Advantage is what your like
somehow weirdly placed to do with your
resources or the things around you you
can figure it out and then apply it
going forward and I think you can kind
of achieve anything so I don't know if
you know what yours
is like the top three like the top one
thing that you've ever achieved that
you're just super proud of it probably
had a method from the start to the
finish of how you got
there H as you were saying that I was
thinking about the very first cohort of
our YouTuber Academy which was like the
first product we released and just
completely exploded the business
overnight basically and that was I had
the idea while I was sitting in a
Starbucks in Cambridge journaling in a
physical pen and paper I was like this
would be a good idea banged it out over
the next several weeks Non-Stop and then
3 weeks later the course was live and
made 30 350k and that was more money
than I'd ever seen before in my life
have you replicated that since with
other things I remember the first
business I started that was successful
again zero to MVP in about 3 weeks I had
the idea while I was at the mosque of
like let me build a company that sells
medical admissions courses and boom we
were up and accepting payments within 3
weeks because I was just like I was like
cool I'm just going to do the thing not
overthinking it not worrying too much
about what people will think and just
having that sort of iterative kind of
mentality so the initial idea comes from
you not being in front of your
laptop yes that's very true the initial
idea comes from you having the space
being somewhere different having a pen
and paper Y and then after that what
made with each of those ideas did you
have the conviction that they would work
straight away I had the conviction that
they might work mhm and so it was like a
lot of this could work let's just give
it a go how many of the ideas that you
write down in your Journal do you think
ah that won't work I'm not going to do
that one quite a lot so there's
something about those ones that made you
think this is worth doing yes so I'd I'd
find almost the metrics around that
because that's probably a system as well
you've probably got like all the ones
that I've written down that I've found
out or that I've thought would work had
these characteristics that they probably
all got in common and then the next
thing you
did was banged it out over the next few
weeks with a team I'm guessing that
probably followed the exact same process
as well solo initially and then the
second one was with a team of just like
all right Scrappy let's just bang stuff
together let's not overthink it let's
just whack it up you know and in both
cases and actually I think in in all
cases I got my hands quite dirty with it
it wasn't like a I'll just sketch out
the vision let the team execute it was
like I'm in making the landing pages
myself and doing the copywriting myself
okay and like in the nuts and bolts of
it so getting Scrappy boots on the
ground taking imperfect action and then
launching yeah and then launching
current current Network current audience
yeah just put and I mean the first time
around I didn't have an audience so I
had to post on the student room and hope
for the best second time around I had
Twitter yes and so Twitter was where I
was and sort of building it in public as
well second time around so this is your
system this is exactly your system
coffee shop idea set of criteria that it
matches taking Scrappy action and then
just doing it you could apply this to
anything going forward your next thing
that you want to achieve yeah this is
the thing so it's like I I'm I'm also
thinking you know when I was writing the
book most of the progress was made in
like very short bursts of time there was
this week where we were at a team
retreat in Wales and some nice Airbnb
and I was like cool my job for this
whole week is just write one chapter a
day MH and from morning to evening I
just like I'm just going to write the
chapter and I wrote like 50,000 words
that week yeah and I've never like
that's by far the most productive I've
ever been in my life in terms of like
word count whereas it took like 2 years
to write 10,000 because I was just like
overthinking and outlining all this sort
of stuff I wonder if some kind of magic
source that works for you is this taking
away the pressure of it being good and
being okay with it being like this is a
disgusting first draft but like it
doesn't matter because it's going to be
like it's going to be fine cuz you
there's probably something in there that
means you trust where it's going to go
so you will accept a level of
imperfection because you know it's kind
of part of the story but you know I
quite like to think about like the movie
of your life like if this was a movie of
your life right now then you there in
your cabin in Wales writing the book
like that would be there and it would be
a really fun scene and it would be like
there's like rain outside and there's
like sheep barring in the distance and
it's like it's this glorious kind of
thing and you're there like and like
scrunching it up and going like that and
like it would be cool it would be cool
there's may be something that's like you
know it's part of the story you know
it's ultimately going to lead to success
that lets you kind of get out your own
way and just put words on the paper
which is powerful because loads of
people can't do that because of the
writer block
thing yeah I think recently we've not
followed the system because we now have
a head of product who's responsible like
you know been wanting to make a
productivity course for a while if ID
followed the system I would have just
like banged it out in 3 weeks and it
would be done but now we're like well
we've got ahead product and we should
like we've got a big audience now it's
kind of a big deal we should do this
properly and therefore we should do the
competitor analysis and we should figure
out what the offer is and we should
follow the methods and yeah all this
kind of stuff and I can see the value in
that but I'm also kind of like feeling
feeling the sense of like I just want to
make it in a weekend yeah because I
think I can make it in a weekend rather
than a six-month period of like back and
forth with with our head of product I
think it's a really valid point and I
think it's almost why startups will
always do well because they don't have
this sense of oh we need to do it
properly whereas like businesses that
have been going a very long time they've
got like policy and HR and procedures
and stuff they have to do so they almost
they almost become irrelevant because
they are following so many different
procedures when the startups are like
we're just going to do we're just going
to execute and we're going to get on
with it so maybe getting back to the the
scrappier the scrappier you might be the
way so I guess just thinking about this
out loud I could do the scrappy version
0.1 soft launch it to like Twitter in
the email list see what happens
and then at that point I lose interest
in it and then I can head it over to a
team team member to take it from 0.1 to
like 100 yeah CU you're the Visionary
yeah you an e and TJ uh yeah yes yeah
we're the same but yeah that's exactly
it the the e means you're super
extrovert the N means the it's like the
Visionary the I've got these great ideas
but then you need someone else to go and
and the t means very very logical the J
means that you can plan it all out but
ultimately you don't even though you
know what the plan should be you don't
want to execute the plan so that's where
yeah team comes in and goes hey there's
all these cool stuff cool things in mind
and they do it sick so how how would
someone go about finding their own
personal success
system think about the things that
you've done that you're most proud of
and not the things that you think you
should be the most proud of but the
things you're really secretly the most
proud of and then figure out what you
did from start to finish to make them
happen and do that with multiple things
and then patterns whatever they are
however weird the patterns are it might
be that everything that you've ever
achieved on a on a really cool level has
always involved this one person or has
always involved this one coffee shop in
Cambridge or whatever it might be find
those patterns and then go to those
people go to those places again and try
and replicate it that's good that's very
good hey friends thank you so much for
watching if you enjoyed this clip then
click here for the full unedited episode
and if you like that then do please
consider subscribing to the channel it
means a lot thank you so much and have a
great day bye-bye